let's start just with how do we get from
something that is not considered a
violent crime or something that is you
know quote-unquote serious how do we end
up putting people in jail how do they
get there versus somebody who gets a
parking ticket they pay it and you know
they could never even imagine going to
jail for something like that yeah I mean
I think one is you start with over
policing right which is who's most
likely to get a ticket right and the
reality is the poor the black or the
brown or the neighborhood the more
likely you are to get a ticket in it the
more likely you are I mean I I did
something with an organization called
the five which is where you go volunteer
in a prison and then it's mostly tech
folks and it was so interesting because
for all these tech folks folks who are
in jail one guy said I've been jail for
seven years I did this and all the tech
looks like I did that I did that and and
so just the stark reality that someone
in America experiences the exact same
thing does the exact same thing and
there are no consequences because they
have the resources to stop the
consequences so one is just starts with
that over policing and so the likelihood
that you're more likely to get a ticket
the more likelihood you look more likely
to be arrested on and then I think the
way it works we've seen it is you might
get a parking ticket and this in some
states it doesn't work like this in some
states you can't go to jail for having a
parking ticket which is great you might
get a parking ticket and then usually
what happens is that you can't afford to
pay it and so either the fee increases
or the consequence happens so it might
be you lose your driver's license
and then you're driving on a driver's
license and you get arrested for a
suspended driver's license
and so one thing is we were sitting in
Michigan and we're talking with some
folks about our software and we were
looking at who are the people most
likely to not show up for court and what
we saw is it was people who were driving
on suspended driver's licenses and so
you thought they were we were talking
about what should they were saying Oh
bail should probably be high and the
idea that it's mostly working people who
have kids who have jobs who are trying
to drive their kids to school and that
those folks are the people that pay the
consequences or face jail because
they're broke
it is is not I think what the system is
designed to do and I think you're seeing
a lot of that right now where people are
saying look the police are not acting in
a way that's consistent with trying to
uphold law it's more about
kind of the oppression of some versus
the oppression of others and and so
that's it so you you end up in jail
basically you can't pay something the
consequences increase and we look at it
like we just started a new software and
the reason we did is because we found
payments were really difficult and so we
launched a second software a second
product called promise pay and the
reason is is because we were looking at
parking tickets how do people end up in
trouble and we looked at one city and we
said how could I look if I want to put
myself on a payment plan and the
requirement was you have 200 ver like
$500 so you have to wait until it's so
expensive then you have to pay 50% up
front then you have to bring your tax
returns to prove that you deserve to put
yourself on a paint plan and you have to
go down to this office downtown during
the work week like it's just the system
isn't designed to make someone
successful and so part we thought about
is how do you build kind of products
that actually are designed for people to
succeed could you imagine if I call my
cable bill and I said I can't pay it and
they said we'll bring your tax returns
come down like this it's not reasonable
yeah and it feels like some of this is
intentional I mean some of it is just
frankly you've got bureaucratic
organizations that have no clue the
realities on the ground right so
something as simple as you know a
quote-unquote good intentioned rule is
hey bring your tax plan we'd love to get
you on a payment plan sounds like we're
helping people but for all the reasons
you're explaining actually end up
causing more and more of a problem right
yeah you know it's weird until I was in
the system I thought it was just like
racism or other folks when you're in it
you realize this is actually designed
that way and the more I minute the more
I see it
I joke that being in a system I've
become a conspiracy theorist and and for
me it was made clear when someone said
to me I said oh this product will work
this way it'll be great and the person
who runs the system said oh that's this
is a difference I don't care about
people in the system and I was like that
level of clarity of just we don't care
about people in the system was was very
important for me to understand I
remember someone saying about a prison
system that we talked to and they said
you know we wouldn't let our dogs be in
this prison
and so the idea that the people who
might be operating a system don't think
that dog their own dog should be in that
system or have no care um speaks to how
the system works and I've definitely
become more I think the system is design
is working the way it was designed to
work so explain that a little bit more
when you say design this way do you mean
design to imprison people and this is
more of like the private prison type you
know issues or is this more of just
putting as many obstacles in place as
possible and then therefore that either
leads to more revenue for the government
and possibly jail time or just clarify
that a little bit to be I think there's
a dehumanization of black and brown
people and in poor people and then I
think it there is just the reality of
the consequences I think no system that
punishes people for not having money is
when it's government it's one thing
right if I get a product and I'm doing
something and then I don't pay for it
that's very different than the
assumption that you're gonna pay for
something that the government provides
or that the consequences like I realized
it where I live they have collate when
you into collections for library fees
and which is you know not does it make
any sense to me so I I think the system
just works in the way and not it
criminalizes things like poverty it
criminalizes and the consequences are
very different if you have good
representation as an example one of
what's been great about our work is we
have people volunteer to help us and we
have had a number of people who have had
issues with the sec try to come to us
and say hey we get the system stinks and
how it's awful and when you have good
representation you face the consequences
are very different than someone who has
bad representation and where we see it
is we see it in someone let's say you
are waiting in court you're well you
have a you know you go to court you have
some type of thing you've been charged
with then you end up waiting in jail
because remember you can't afford bail
so you're sitting in jail then you take
a plea deal and the plea deal has no
time associated with it but you can go
back to jail with a technical violation
a technical violation could be you miss
a meal with your probation on
officer you go to what we saw an example
someone got married outside of the
counties they technically left the
county and so people end up in jail a
lot for technical violations and often
because due process goes away with a
technical violation so you don't have a
right to a trial in the same way anymore
and so that's I think how the system
doesn't work is I can't afford to get
out so I take a plea deal that might not
make sense for me and then I end up in
trouble as a technical violation that
takes away due process